hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros en france 24 cerrado blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos en
brásil el final de 2020 estuvo marcado
por el fallecimiento un hombre negro
quien fue golpeado hasta la muerte por
los guardias de un supermercado
carrefour en la ciudad de porto alegre
después de este crimen se organizaron
una serie de manifestaciones frente a la
supermercados carrefour en todo el
territorio pero antes de eso ese mismo
año la lucha racial brasileña se
organizaba en las semanas anteriores a
estos acontecimientos nuestros
corresponsales en ese país acompañaron
al movimiento black light manos de
brasil frente al racismo profundamente
arraigado en una nación donde el 56 por
ciento de la población es negra en
comparación con el 13 por ciento de eeuu
los movimientos negros están ganando
terreno en la educación la política y la
prensa en este reportaje nos sumergimos
en el movimiento de la lucha racial
brasileña veamos el siguiente reportaje
[Música]
30 de septiembre de 2020 estamos en sao
gonçalo una de las zonas más pobres del
estado del río de janeiro
[Música]
no hay nada peor que ver la vida de un
niño interrumpida por el racismo
estructural que experimentamos en las
favelas de nuestra ciudad más comunidad
cosas
rafaela asiste al primer homenaje en
memoria de su hijo abatido durante una
operación policial contra un traficante
hace cuatro meses en medio de la crisis
de coronavirus guau pedro estaba jugando
en la casa de sus primos cuando fue
víctima de las balas de los policías que
invadieron por error la casa familiar
tenía 14 años
joao pedro deja la imagen de un joven
muy aplicado apoyado por su familia todo
el mundo lo sabe y aquellos que no lo
conocían lo conocen hoy por esta
tragedia
[Música]
su padre madre abuelas tías y hermana
menor están de luto por la vida que le
arrebataron una semana antes de la de
georges lloyd en eeuu
bajo la sombra de la revuelta tan
mediatizada que vivió el país
norteamericano brasil quedó en el olvido
sin embargo su fuerza policial es la más
violenta del mundo y mata 17 veces más
negros que la fuerza policial
estadounidense en casi total
indiferencia
[Música]
por aquí al lado de los padres del
ropero espero que les guste esta paula
díaz
ella es quien creó el proyecto de la
sala de lectura en nombre de la o pedro
este es su espacio
entre dentro
paula dirige una ong que trabaja por los
jóvenes negros de los suburbios como
natan que estaba con solo pedro el día
en que murió volver mi esposo es negro
mi hijo natan también y nos sentimos
obligados a pedirle que adapten su
comportamiento debido al color de su
piel le pedimos que sea más amable de lo
normal
somos más estrictos con él porque como
es negro tiene que ser irreprochable
ante los ojos de la sociedad no debería
ser así todos somos iguales sin importar
el color de la santidad al igual que el
robo pedro 12 niños negros murieron
debido a las balas perdidas en 2020 sólo
en el estado de río de janeiro la última
tragedia tuvo lugar a finales de
diciembre
género dos crianzas mujer en baleares en
frente a la puerta de casa demasiado
feminista
emily y rebeca primas de cuatro y siete
años fueron víctimas de los barrios
pobres todas las víctimas son negras una
violencia racial a la que paula díaz
responde con cultura
[Música]
aquel día de noviembre la activista
inauguró el coro vidas negras importan
que en portugués significa las vidas
negras importan
[Música]
mira
m
la enseñanza de la historia de la
cultura afro brasileña es obligatoria
las escuelas de 1996 sin embargo rara
vez se enseña en el aula
aquí vamos a valorizar la cultura afro
porque la conocemos muy poco y quiero
mostrarles que nosotros los negros
podemos hacer lo que queramos podemos
hacer nuestros sueños realidad vamos a
luchar para que se conviertan en grandes
músicos
descendientes de los 4 millones de
africanos que fueron llevados a la
fuerza a brasil no todos estos niños
saben que su país fue el mayor
territorio esclavista de américa
mi tatarabuela era africana no perdón
era una esclava
creo que el embargo
con agua te equivocas si tu tatarabuela
era africana la trajeron a brasil para
esclavizarlas y fue esclavizados
sus hijos y nietos son brasileños
descendientes de esclavos entiendes
el racismo se infiltra en la vida
cotidiana de estos jóvenes que a menudo
permanecen en silencio frente a nuestras
cámaras se animan a hablar
a mí mismo
un día estaba en el parque con mi
hermana mi hermano y mi abuela
había algunas chicas blancas jugando así
que les pregunté si podíamos jugar con
ellas nos dijeron no solo pueden
participar los blancos aquí no hay
espacio para los negros entonces nos
fuimos y una de ellas nos llamó monos
y dijo que nuestro cabello era duro
nunca le dijimos a nuestra abuela
una juventud constantemente discriminada
a la que paula e intenta inculcar el
orgullo por su color de piel
[Música]
para curar las heridas de la esclavitud
brasileña también se libra una lucha en
la política días antes de las elecciones
municipales la campaña electoral está en
pleno apogeo en campo grande es en este
barrio popular donde se ha ir bolsonaro
tuvo la mayor votación de río durante
las elecciones presidenciales de 2018
por primera vez en la historia del país
hay más candidatos negros que blancos en
las elecciones municipales y
principalmente mujeres negras buenos
días soy renata souza candidata a la
alcaldía de río como están
[Música]
renata souza ha sido diputada del estado
de río de janeiro durante los dos
últimos años y también fue jefa de
gabinete de mar y el franco una
concejala local que defendía los
derechos humanos y la causa negra que
fue asesinada a principios de 2018
cruzo los dedos para que seas elegida
trabajaste con mariel la adoraba aún no
puedo creer que la hayan matado era
brillante no sé qué decir pueda intentar
convencer a la gente de que vote por ti
al parecer mariel fue asesinada con arma
de fuego por milicianos cercanos al
presidente bolsonaro su muerte deja un
gran legado o nazismo fundó
el racismo fundó brasil tenemos la
oportunidad de rehacer la historia con
hombres negros mujeres negras que entren
en el poder estamos aquí para abrir la
posibilidad de superar las desigualdades
sociales a partir de los intereses
comunes
la entrada de la población negra en la
política es una cuestión de vida o
muerte
o una emergencia que el actual gobierno
niega a pesar de que todos sus 17
ministros son blancos pero el presidente
de jair bolsonaro procura mostrarse con
las pocas figuras públicas negras que lo
apoyan
como el diputado federal elio lópez
durante sus alocuciones semanales en sus
redes sociales el presidente se refiere
a él regularmente
el gran hombre negro es el yo lo
considero mi hermano salvo que tardó un
poco más en salir venga aquí van a ver
que está un poco demasiado bronceado si
no tendría mi misma cara apodado la
sombra de bolsonaro o su compañero negro
por los opositores
elio lópez apoya incondicionalmente a
yair bolsonaro y afirma que los
movimientos negros sólo existen para
dividir al país en esta foto a la
derecha está el yo lópez a la izquierda
sergio camargo otra figura negra que se
opone a la lucha contra la
discriminación racial a finales de 2019
fue nombrado director de la fundación
cultural de palmares el único organismo
público encargado de defender la cultura
afro brasileña
por supuesto que tenemos que dejar de
conmemorar la conciencia negro es un
tema que la izquierda ha aprovechado
para propagar el odio desde su
nombramiento no ha dejado de atacar a
los movimientos negros llamando los
esclavos ideológicos de la izquierda
pero también ha atacado a periodistas
como pedro borges en sao paulo pedro
fundó alma prêt à una agencia de
periodismo especializada en temas
raciales
entonces qué noticias tenemos hoy tiene
una cita con su abogado para discutir su
demanda por difamación que lo enfrenta
precisamente a sergio camargo
lo que pasó es que me atacó yo le seguía
en las redes sociales hasta que un día
me bloqueó y luego me atacó públicamente
el presidente de la fundación palmares
dice que victimizó a los negros que
estoy a favor de la segregación racial
que soy anti blanco y lo más grave y me
acusa de defender a bandidos lo cual es
un delito
ataques en las redes sociales noticias
falsas una técnica que según pedro el
actual gobierno utiliza para
desacreditar la lucha racial
es una de las figuras que representan el
contexto actual y se utilizan los negros
como portavoces de una agenda muy
conservadora para hacer que se pierda lo
que la población negra ha alcanzado una
manera de promover retrocesos y todas
esas conquistas que la población negro
es muy importante defender a un
periodista negro sabe que como negro
tuvo que atravesar todos los obstáculos
de nuestro país para convertirse en
periodista defenderlo es defender la
libertad de expresión el derecho a la
información y el derecho a ejercer la
profesión de periodista pues todos estos
derechos consagrados en nuestra
constitución deben aplicarse a todos los
brasileños pero no es así estamos
retroceder en 2013 de indonesia
[Música]
un paso atrás siendo que los negros y
los mestizos representan ahora el 56 de
la población de brasil
[Música]
en río renata souza se prepara para
votar en su barrio para el mayor grupo
de favelas de la ciudad
en la entrada de la escuela que fue
convertida en centro de votación hay
algunas cámaras y simpatizantes del
barrio
todo un trabajo las puertas
y les digo a todos los que pasan por
aquí que voten por ella porque
representa a las mujeres negras de las
favelas trabajamos muy duro para
alimentar a nuestras familias pero no
tenemos derecho a nadie somos
constantemente discriminados porque
somos negros necesitamos poner a una
mujer negra a cargo porque ella sabe lo
que necesitamos
voten por renata
[Música]
es la primera vez que un candidato a
alcalde de río vota en una favela pero
cuando es momento de entrar
[Música]
es porque estamos en una favela porque
vengo de acá porque soy negro no se le
permite el acceso a la prensa que como
nosotros desea acompañar el momento
simbólico del voto de la candidata
a diferencia de los otros candidatos
importantes de la ciudad
renata souza vota sola y sale con un
sabor amargo
[Música]
el estado democrático de derecho nos
revela su cara más racista y prejuiciosa
qué clase de democracia es la que impide
que se grabe el voto de un candidato de
la favela es muy simbólico muestra lo
mucho que nos queda por recorrer
no puede ser tomado un simbólico también
eso también es así
menos mal que vieron lo que pasó o si no
no me habrían creído
con solo 85 mil votos la candidata no
pasó de la primera ronda pero en estas
elecciones se lograron algunas victorias
en la lucha contra el racismo en varias
ciudades hubo un ligero aumento en el
número de concejales negros y mestizos
como en sao paulo unos días después de
las elecciones el simbólico día nacional
de la conciencia negra reúne a unos
cientos de personas en la avenida
principal
[Música]
ahora pondremos el tema de la raza y la
mujer en el centro del debate político
erika hilton desafía al gobierno actual
a sus 27 años esta activista es la
primera mujer negra transexual que se
convierte en consejera municipal en la
capital económica del país
pero este año el día de la conciencia
nacional estuvo marcado por una terrible
noticia
[Música]
hoy se levantaron los puños por su lado
alberto un hombre negro de 40 años que
fue golpeado hasta la muerte el día
anterior por los guardias de seguridad
en un supermercado carrefour en
portoalegre la gota que colmó el vaso
para la recién representante electa de
la ciudad lo que ocurrió en portoalegre
sólo ilustra el racismo que existe hoy
en día en brasil
esta muerte rompe la idea de que brasil
no es un país racista mientras vivamos
bajo la ilusión de una democracia racial
no podremos enfrentar la realidad no
podremos combatir las estadísticas de
muerte de la población negra es un
genocidio en brasil- el 75% de las
víctimas de homicidio son personas
negras cifras inaceptables para pedro
borges que hoy cubre el mitin para su
periódico 23 minutos mueren georges voy
de aquí en brasil pero si los brasileños
reaccionarán con la misma fuerza que los
movimientos negros en eeuu seríamos
ejecutados encarcelados
la represión del estado aquí es tan
fuerte que dificulta la movilización
bajo las cámaras de alma aprieta la
agencia de pedro la multitud comienza a
moverse hacia el supermercado carrefour
más cercano
la revuelta se intensifica
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un viento de indignación que se extiende
más pacíficamente en los días siguientes
en porto alegre belo horizonte e incluso
brasilia
[Aplausos]
o como dos días después en los suburbios
del norte de río
[Aplausos]
frente al carrefour de un centro
comercial más de 300 personas enojadas
piden boicotear a la cadena de
supermercados francesa
manifestaciones en todo el país pero
sobre todo una calidad de más del 5% en
la bolsa brasileña bajo presión el grupo
carrefour brasil anunció las medidas
tomadas sin contratos administrativos
destinados a personas negras un paso
adelante en un país donde solo ocupan el
10% de estos puestos
a paso
las vidas negras importan
[Música]
el movimiento anti racista finalmente
obligó a las empresas brasileñas a
mostrar solidaridad con los
afrodescendientes
una grieta que se abrió por fin ante la
urgencia de la necesidad de un cambio
hasta aquí esta emisión de reporteros
nos vemos en una próxima oportunidad
hasta pronto
[Música]